hello everyone my name is Sarah and I'm
here with mr. Eddie wound math teacher
at cherrybrook technology high school
and today we're going to talk a little
bit about why is teaching so awesome and
why you might want to go into it and
also why people don't think to go into
it perhaps when they leave school
so Eddie I just like to ask you first
can you tell us a little bit about your
trajectory into teaching in white
choices sure thing I I was not always
going to be a teacher I it was not on my
top three list as a little little boy
yeah I really wanted to be a fireman yes
super top secret spy yeah all those
kinds of yeah but as I grew became a
teenager it's sad to realize okay one of
the skills that I have and what do I
enjoy yeah doing teaching the job I
realized pretty quickly that in a class
whenever there be you know the teachers
explaining to a concept and then we all
start doing our own work and whenever
someone had trouble with something I
don't missed out of instinct yeah jump
into that and say oh you thought about
it this way yeah or no the way I
understand it you and I just go from
there and just felt natural
yeah in some ways yeah so I took that
idea and I realized that you know not
only did I like to be part of that
process
yeah but I really loved seeing what
could happen when someone really wrap
their head around an idea I just got
kind of that's that idea that experience
it sunk its teeth into me yeah and I
thought well this is really cool I can I
can contribute to other people have that
experience so it's like what the love of
the lightbulb moment yeah that's exactly
right yeah now I should say it's kind of
where it started
and I feel very fortunate in that when I
when I started along the path of
becoming a teacher and experiencing
teaching for the first time much to my
pleasant surprise I ended up discovering
more
or things about it that I love and so
yeah I think that I began all of the
journey just thinking about I want to
use my skills and what am I enjoy doing
but along the way I've just picked up
all these other things yourself Wow so
it's interesting that you say that you
kind of acknowledge that there are a
vast amount of the skills that you had
that were you know in line with the
teaching profession and what's really
great is that you're able to say well
this is in line with teaching and I love
teaching therefore I will do teaching
but it's not always the experience with
a lot of young people as has been my
experience I went through doing a
science degree at Sydney Uni and was
tutoring actually along the way and
really really enjoyed tutoring but
didn't think that teaching would be
something I should do because when
you've done reasonably well at high
school level and you've got the smarts
and you're interested in say science or
business or whatever it's more logical
to go well I shouldn't waste my oxygen
waste my skills I should go and do
something else so now I realised just
like you that my passions and my skills
are in likely teaching and that's what
I'd really like to do but how can we get
young people to think about teaching
more positively and actually entertain
the idea of going into it if maybe
medicine law is really attractive
I got loads ideas there's no there's no
there's no silver bullet I guess I think
if there were some really quick easy
direct solution yeah people would have
thought about because people have been
in fact I remember back in it's not just
teaching in general but also specific
kinds of teaching yeah that particular
struggle and I know mathematics er
science teaching a particular area yes I
suppose partly because if you have
skills in mathematics and science then
there is a whole range you know a
plethora of other opportunities that
open themselves up see which are equally
valuable as well because science and
math is our own it's the way that
technological advancements in the world
keeps on chugging along truth so when I
when I decided to interact with math I
realized that
there's there are real obstacles to like
on an institutional level that all right
for instance in Eddie in any kind of
normal industry right things go along in
terms of pricing in that they go with
supply and demand sure when there's low
supply with this high demand things
become more valuable now because of the
nature of the teaching profession that's
that supply and demand sort of equation
doesn't really result in a different way
in fact sometimes it can even go in
reverse so there's a mathematics teacher
you know I'll go to a party and I'll you
know everyone start to say ah you know
what's your name what do you do and
they'll say teacher way to teach you
know high school what do you teach and
as soon as people find out I'm a
mathematics teacher no one ever says oh
thank goodness that you are because
that's a really Rick never ones response
like that yeah this what was the
opposite response
oh I hated math I was really bad at that
I had this really terrible experience
yeah and so the first thing is that
there's that that reality that it's
almost you can't wake reality yes but at
the same time you know there's a sort of
that's like sort of a top-down yeah this
bottom-up reality that you teachers in
schools often are our our worst enemies
why I personally was not really
encouraged to what's going into teaching
but my teachers you know hey kid do all
these other things so what did you waste
your life in teaching which quite
especially if you're hearing from a
teacher you think okay you don't do a
good job and so I think that there's
both of those aspects which feed into
their 4th of wider cultural reason why a
country like ours as opposed to do
plenty of other countries out there you
know Scandinavian countries Asian
countries that really hold
teaching as a highly regarded career
so it's part of a big picture I guess
what I would say is in terms of the
kinds of strategies that I would think
are you know helpful is first just
having the conversations because I
remembered it myself the kinds of
conversations I had and the directions
they went in and the disappointing ways
they were okay I thought okay well if if
conversations can have that kind of
effect then I think they can have the
opposite truth is what dr. dwelle that's
right and that's it that's a simple
small thing but I think it has
tremendous power and I've seen I've seen
the fruit of that I'm gonna say some of
my most proud words I haven't been
teaching that long in the scheme of
things but I've been teaching you long
enough that I've had some of my own
students come to me and say you know
people who I've known really could do
anything and they said you know what I
want to become a teacher and you know
the moment says happened I think I felt
like my heart was going to pop because
it was just an enormous sense of joy and
pride that people who have these
tremendous skills for the great
communicators and have incredible minds
are going to be in the future in a place
where they can share that mm absolutely
yes I think that's those little things
they can't have tremendous events yeah I
think there's definitely a need for
valuing the teaching contribution a lot
more than is currently happening because
you know as a student when you've had a
good teacher every student at a school
knows who the teachers are that they
really enjoy and perhaps who the
teachers are that they don't look
forward to their classes as much it's a
sad reality but it is true and you know
ask any student and they will tell you
as much so it's the impact that you can
make is phenomenal you think if you're
teaching 30 kids in a class they could
go on to as you say do anything whether
it be teaching or some other kind of
line of work wow what a value what a
contribution to society to shape the
features of kids who are going to grow
up to become adults who are then going
to shape our world it's just so
important and I think it's amazing that
right now we're getting like this
strange dichotomy of hey STM education
is really really important and we
but also this is you know teaching are
you don't wanna go to teaching do you
that's nice do or do medicine it's
really odd I think students have a right
to be confused about the mixed messages
they're getting but as you say it's
really important to start those
conversations and not necessarily funnel
people into tutor tutoring or teaching
just saying why is that you really want
to do what is it that you are really
passionate about right now and why don't
you go explore that for a while and then
see how it goes if you like it keep
going if you don't change there's
there's so much need for those kinds of
conversations I think I also think that
I mean there's a real I mean in some
ways the elephant in the room is that
even though there are some bad reasons
for why you know teaching is not held up
as a high professions there are some
absolutely valid reasons you know um
just to put it out there really hollow
its and especially you know as a person
who even as a person who from a fairly
early point wanted to become a teacher I
remember thinking to myself the first
time I you know God you know my first
year 7 class and I thought he's 7 how
can you serve me I did you serve it and
I'm this is a difficult can it be and I
was absolutely unprepared for what a
challenge it would be to take this big
energetic group of individuals to be
able to go to know them and to guide
them individually to learn and explore a
whole variety of different concepts that
I not only had to understand for my own
brain but I had to understand it into 30
different ways and I had to I had to be
able to predict what the 30 different
kinds of misconceptions were all those
little things not to mention all the
things you're doing outside the
classroom then that's support teaching
but also they just they take up time not
to mention you know those those thirty
students they are just stares they're
human beings they have they have their
own story that have their own background
they have their own context in which
they exist and we are a part of that we
enter into that story
and we're very often no idea what kinds
of struggles they're dealing and
therefore what struggles they bring with
them into the classroom
exactly so teaches is really really hard
and so I guess in some ways what we want
to have in perspective is that like I
don't want to to talk all the things I
love that teaching even though I have
hundreds of it yeah and give people the
wrong idea I definitely think it's the
kind of thing where you know for
instance I would never say Oh coming to
teaching because there are wonderful
holidays the hours are fantastic yeah
that's a lie the cake is a lie it's it's
yeah that is misrepresentee yeah just be
sitting and also we'll bring the wrong
people into the profession very slightly
honestly we get a variance prize and
would necessarily be good for our
students so I guess the way I think
about it is a little bit like I don't
know how many people familiar with with
JFK u.s. President was getting up and
was explaining why as a country they
wanted to go to the food right he has
this big famous speech that he gave to
Rice University and one of the things he
says which on which stuck with me
because I studied speeches in year 12 is
I'm gonna be enjoyed it yeah very lucky
you could do a lot worse than speeches
and III those those speeches were so
interesting I thought I want to go and
find out what other great speeches there
are out there that are really powerful
and which have you know affected social
change it's just amazing that Oh
something one person can say every small
amount of time can just change history
you know and so one of the phrases from
his speech that stuck with me is why are
we going to the moon and he says you why
we might as well ask why climb Everest
you know it's so difficult it's
sociology or the answer is we do them
not not in spite of the fact that
they're that difficult challenging we do
them precisely because they will
exercise our abilities they'll challenge
our skills they'll make us grow and
accomplish things we never thought we
could do precisely because they are
difficult and so I have you teaching in
that similar kind of a
it'd be difficult and it'd be exhausting
and in some ways you know not respected
as much as it should be
for me that's part of the challenge I
mean that's part of looking at the peak
and saying I'm probably gonna half
diamond up but yeah but when I get there
yeah I'll be able to look back and say I
overcome these challenges and that's
what makes this achievement that's a
part that's a big part of what makes
this even so great and so valuable that
it would require you know facing look
like it's an animal eyes and emerging
successful in victorious and effective
at the other side nonetheless it's
interesting that it has quite a lot of
parallels with the HSC itself doesn't it
it's another big thing in your life that
you're working towards and there are a
lot of challenges but eventually you
overcome it and it feels amazing but I
think the difference between perhaps
teaching is a career and the HFCS the
HSC is a sprint run whereas teaching if
you're passionate about it but you want
to do it well is going to be a marathon
effort but there are definitely some
people out there we've got the stamina
and the fitness to do it just like you
so you know this is why we need people
like you in teaching definitely well I
definitely think that I have it could be
really easy to be a bit reductionistic
and to think how you doing there are
teachers out there who you know they
don't portray very proficient in the
best light but I've got to say I have
absolutely respect for anyone who's been
you know at this really hard work for 25
30 35 years longer than I've been alive
and they're theatres are really
dedicated to it and and have seen
through hundreds thousands of students
and have put themselves out I think that
one of the things that makes teaching
the hardest is also what makes it the
best infant what's hard about teaching
is that the job is number one it's never
robot there's no there's no point in
which you can say oh okay I don't I put
the four doors one of the engines in the
tires are on set that car at the factory
cuz it's finished you could always make
the the lesson flashier and you
make the resource you know Richard you
can spend more time helping your
students individually and it's
never-ending
yeah there's that factor and there's
also the fact that you know when you
teach I'm a big believer in the fact
that you're not just there to you know
convey some ideas and to give some
people some skills you are like you're
shaping as I'm saying before human
beings you have this enormous
opportunity to do that but that takes
the entirety of your person my part of
the reason why it's exhausting is not
just because you're physically on your
feet but you invest in your students
yeah and I think we should invest in our
students and be you know emotionally
moved by their success or their
difficulty or whatever it is they come
in through absolutely I think that's how
you know teachers who I I had who I love
and respect they invested in me and I
felt the benefits so the combination of
those two things they are both a
privilege but they're also what makes
teaching so you know they are because
you're giving of yourself
of your own character your personality
and every aspect of who you are that is
not easy I would agree that it's
definitely so worth it though because I
find myself at home you know
understanding they're not working
through some four unit problem thinking
why am I doing this why am I doing this
but you finish it and then you think yes
I've got it and then you go and give it
to a student and they explain it to them
and then they go yes I got it too and
it's just like so worth it that moment
is so worth it and then the students do
it as well I'm I'm very privileged in
that I've I've not just I've tried my
best to be as good a teacher as I could
be but you know you also play the hand
you're dealt and it's a pity of where
you are
some students like I said they depending
on the background or the context they
have so be challenges of the bear face
that's you know sometimes just being at
school is it incredibly cheaper yeah
just finishing in HSC let alone what you
get for your agency that can be and that
can be the enormous mountain that you're
trying to climb absolutely
and their own different parameters that
they're working with and what success
might be for one person is different
kind of thing for another person I often
see students who have come through maybe
you know you're 11 or year 10 with
considerable health problems whether it
be physical or mental yeah they'll come
and they'll say oh I really need some
tutoring in some academic support
because I've missed the whole chunk of
school and I'm really confused in class
now so to see them finish the HSC really
thriving is an amazing achievement
because they're in such better shape
than they were when they started
academically yes of course but also in
so many other aspects that are equally
important so I think it's interesting
it's coming through pretty much
everything you've been saying that
teaching is yes about understanding
content but also about relating to a
student and getting the best out of them
and developing them as a person I think
this state as far as the HSC is
concerned if some is providing an
interesting environment for students to
to work in at the moment because well
sure I mean it's different depending on
which school you go to but there is a
lot of pressure on students to succeed
academically often at the cost of their
health and happiness so I'm interested
to know what do you do in your
classrooms to make sure that the whole
person is catered for yeah well that is
a huge question to ask the hard
questions have the most interesting
courses I think that the first thing and
the first thing I'd say which almost
feels like art is a is just to firstly
be explicit about the fact fans and you
know I like to do this um at the at the
start of a school year you sort of set
expectations a little kind of thing and
I also like to do it sort of a regular
in tools because obviously we forget
yeah it's just to get up there and as
the teacher to say look my
responsibility here as a teacher is to
you know ensure that you are going to
learn
that's my chief responsibility
but I have more responsibilities than
that you know I am I I'm here to be an
educator and mushroom don't know the
word educate actually comes from of the
word to lead out which is like you know
to lead out from darkness from
immaturity from just ignorance of the
whole world and so that's about so much
more than just fill your mind with more
information stuff it's about I want to
grow in character I want to grow in my
outlook of the world and understand it
more deeply I don't want to understand
myself and other human beings more
deeply and that's my job to like that's
part of my role and to say that to
students can often be really like it's
kind of shocking whoa okay it's like
isn't that is that is that really where
he fought in the Internet in fatica Lee
yes and to hear that articulated firstly
I think that's really powerful
me too I don't think it's enough by
itself but to say that like it always
gives students permission to say I
really one of the things I like to say
in my classes is that you know I'm gonna
treat you like a human being and I
expect you to do the same to me and even
though that seems obvious I think in the
teacher-student relationship sometimes
we can get that yeah absolutely
like I I know my friends as well people
who would look a teacher in the eye and
completely lie to them about I didn't do
my homework or do
or whatever it was and pilots because
like I've forgotten that you're a human
being
I would not be I would not be dishonest
in that way just that something so small
really do anyone except it's it's almost
as if different rules functioning in a
classroom and to sort of put that to one
side say actually you know what we're
both yes I'm the teacher and yes you're
the student but we are both you these in
this class you know we deserve the
dignity of treating each other with that
kind of so I think that's firstly a many
powerful motive but secondly I guess
like I was saying it's not enough just
to say things we have to back that up
with action tree and I think if I could
just point to one one practical things
that has been obviously helpful to
demonstrate that I really in action I'm
living out what I said at the start of
the year in words is that you know okay
so there's 30 students and this school
the lessons are just a bit shy of an
hour yeah so if you could tell me and
you call that a no okay probably half of
that time is going to be given over to
you know standing up at explaining stuff
or helping you know particular students
in the room get around to different
resources or wrap their head around
different concepts etc that leaves you
with like maybe optimistically one
minute per student to go and have this
holistic human conversation about hey
how are you going that don't go to work
your actions in what yours what you're
doing and you're saying at the start of
the year and also intervals hey I really
care about you essentially that does
open up the opportunity for a student to
go like I really cares maybe I'll go and
check in with him after the lesson if I
have a specific issue that I'm not going
to get time to cover in the lesson
that's the other benefit of teachers and
tutors of course is that you can provide
that extra support to a student beyond
what sort of time constrains you to it
in the classroom
I should add like I am i paint it very
dark but I actually think at the same
time you know as teachers we math
teacher so I guess I'll do this for you
you know we get this tremendous lake and
and breath of time interacting
person-to-person students oh okay let's
call it an hour I know that I get about
eight lessons per fortnight with my
students generally yeah resuit let's
call that eight hours yeah right there
are 24 nights in a year so that's like a
hundred and sixty hours with these
students life to life face to face and
it's just sometimes it's not the big
thing that I get up and I I'm really
really deliberate about it's just when
that student asked me a question I did
just shut down
I didn't even necessarily go to answer
immediately I just said that's a plain
question yeah I'll be with you two
minutes and that's a value a question
and I value your time enough yeah speech
about it sometimes those little things
over the course of that time I said 160
hours or students in clock it in classes
that just that maths class for you know
for most students like a thousand hours
yeah and that's conserved because you
get to see the playground yeah and the
effect you can have over that time of
just all those little decisions and
little conversations and little
interactions even just the way you look
someone in the eye and give them the
time of day and pay attention to them
when they're giving you a question with
a problem with done yeah that has it an
incredible communities so I guess that's
how I try and communicate Hey yes
academics are really important you
should absolutely excel as far as you
can but there's more to being a child
and a stupid human being and often what
does happen is academics is important
and you should focus on those most
definitely but when you finish your HSC
and you get out into the real world
which all the teachers are always
telling us about you know when I was
going through when you get into the rule
but like when you do you realize that
yes
these qualities are important you need
to learn the ability to interact with
the difficult problem and provide a
solution in some way yes that's true but
also your ability to communicate and to
be a good person and treat other people
as a good person as good people I mean
that's that goes a long way in any
workplace and that's one thing that I've
realized you know you can you can work
very hard you can produce great results
but if you feel like you're being
treated well and that you're treating
other people well the world just sings
and that's what we should all be looking
for teaching or not student or not I
think yeah so I guess I've in many ways
fall in love with the idea that I can
help so many people in a really
substantial way as well arrive at that
and you know I mean just as an example
if you come to this realization in your
whole life you know these kinds of
people skills or those kinds of
cognitive skills I'm really telling you
that right so maybe you go to like a
psychologist or a life coach or a train
or someone who could assist you with
that night you get those skills and you
see the memory a short period of time
you develop the skill and then off you
go once you've got that and the
privilege of a teacher is that we get to
we're the opportunity to see students
over this amount of time which honestly
this is one of things I love that
secondary taking particular student said
to you seven wrong and they you know
they're so why would possibility but
they're also people who need so much
support there are many things they don't
know how to do yet yeah and by the time
they leave you twelve they're these
incredible independent self driven
making decisions for themselves type
people you know just to see that happen
that transformation happen and then on
top of that to be able to contribute
that little pot is a it's an amazing
thing to see it
I think that's been an excellent chat
hopefully that's inspired some people to
think about the possibility of going
into teaching if they have this
empathetic sighted them and want to
contribute in that way to students lives
and their growth and development over
what is now thirteen year journey so
thank you so much for speaking to me
anyway
it's it's lovely to see your classroom
as well I do feel a little bit sad that
I'm not currently still studying maths
at HSC level but I don't miss extension
to it I am shooting it so it's it's
still still kicking around okay sir no
worries awesome